[ Quiz: What does s, t = t, s do? ]
So, the answer is, it actually swaps the value of "s" and "t."
This is quite convenient,
and the important reason for that is
both the values on the right side get evaluated first--
to get turned into their values--
before we do any of the assignments.
So, what's going on:
"s" refers to some value--
let's call that "alpha"--
and "t" refers to some value--
we'll call that "beta."
This is before the assignments.
To evaluate the multiple assignment expression,
we find the value of "t" here [indicating the second "t" in the expression]--
that has the value of "beta"--
and we find the value of "s"--
and "s" has the value of "alpha."
We've evaluated both of these,
and we've turned them into the values the names refer to;
and, now we do the assignments.
So, "s" will be changed to refer to the first value--
which is "beta" –
and "t" will be changed to refer to the second value.
This has very different behavior
than if we did two assignments like this;
so, if we tried, instead, doing "assign t to s,"
and then "assign s to t,"
that wouldn't swap the values,
because, by the time we do the second assignment,
the value of "s" has changed--
now it refers to whatever the value of "t" was.
If we had done these two statements {indicating "s = t" and "t = s"],
both of them would end up having the value "beta."